[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Dave mcmenamin ESPN NBA reporter in
attendance for Victor wambayama's Summer
League games kind enough to join us Dave
give me the uh atmosphere of those two
games and is there anything comparable
with Victor 1 bayama's debuts
well Friday was off the charts uh I
would say two three hours before tip-off
you had Thompson Mack Center it was on
unlv's campus was already about 90
percent full uh and ended up being this
excellent crowd for Jabari Smith Jr and
the Houston Rockets to pull off a
last-second win against the Portland
Trailblazers
um you know you had I was talking to
Brent Barry who you know you guys
remember Brandon was a dunk contest
Champion a long time NBA player he works
for the Spurs front office and he's like
you know Victor has Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
sitting on one Baseline to watch his
debut Jerry West on the other he's like
my summer league debut in Long Beach
wasn't anything like that uh and it was
just teeming with uh you know the
glitterati of the NBA you look one place
there's Jason Beverly Hills the guy who
makes the championship rings for
everybody look somewhere else you have
Jeff Hamilton the guy who makes those
leather uh gaudy jackets that the
Champions wear and then beyond that of
course every team's front office
um and I'm not just talking about the GM
I'm talking about the GM all the way
down to the last data guy was in the
stands
um just you know hoping to see some
history and obviously we know that the
Victor didn't play all that well on
Friday
um but yesterday with you know I guess
with some of the pressure off uh he was
incredible uh 27 points 12 rebounds
three block shots
um led a the comeback by the Spurs uh
late in that game it's a three-pointer
when they're down four with about two
minutes to go to cut it to one and the
roof was ready to come off the building
and Victor's gonna now shut it down uh
for the remainder of the summer league
and now he has that mole on that very
strong performance to give him
confidence going in a training camp yeah
reacted on Friday and they're probably
overreacting on Sunday
um and I'm I'm just looking for what I
think is sustainable I I think it you
know what he does on the defensive end
is going to be impactful right away
offensively it looked like he you know
he takes off balance jumpers like he
he's still not quite sure but
defensively I just think if they keep a
stat for shots altered I I think that
that would be interesting to combine he
might not get blocked shots you know a
couple months into the season the way he
did it to start because guys are going
to be like I know I can't go in there
and do that but that's the the feeling I
get and he seems like he's
he dunks politely
he he doesn't block with you know this
authoritative I'm going to send it into
the seventh row like there's I I he just
feels like uh calm like he's there's a
calming dominance to him certainly on
the defensive end
well Jerry West that did an interview
and compared him to Bill Russell and
obviously that's you know the the
greatest winner in NBA history uh but
when you mention the fact that you don't
see the ferocity on his block shots you
know Russell's a guy that always was
credited for why am I not block the ball
into the stands when I can block it and
Corral it get it to a teammate and all
of a sudden we're off on a fast break
and certainly he has that ability
defensively he was exposed a little bit
in the Charlotte game the first game in
terms of getting switched out into the
perimeter and Brandon Miller kind of had
his way out there and that will be part
of his development the lateral quickness
and certainly uh for him to continue to
be as effective as he has been with
eight blocks in these two Summer League
games when it comes to the big boys he's
gonna have to put bulk up a bit I'm not
saying change his frame completely you
know back in the day Kevin Durant people
said boy oh you can only you know rep
225 pounds with the uh bench press that
many times isn't that a problem you no
and clearly it hasn't been but just the
overall strengthening of his body will
help him because he's got to be bounced
around a lot and I I think at some point
he's going to be targeted by some of
these these veteran teams because they
recognize
um you know whether I don't know
jealousy is the right word but the hype
train is coming 100 miles per hour with
this guy and uh he's not quite a fully
formed product yeah yeah but I wonder
you know who's going at him and where
are they going at him if they do
switches well he does have that wingspan
that even if you're you know I'm four
feet away from you I can still affect
your shot he won't have the quickness to
stay with these guards but you know I
watch that with Joe Ellen bead in the
NBA Playoffs he got abused by Jason
Tatum on the perimeter it happens to
these guys but none of those guys has
the you know the wingspan that Victor
won by Emma he might get switched out
but he's gonna he's gonna affect some
shots out there and he also also said I
don't need to bulk up like you you know
are these guys going to be able to keep
up with him because I did notice this if
he blocks a shot or there's a rebound
he's out on the break
like he re he goes he's ready to go and
I want to see if these big men are able
to go when he goes as well so he he does
have strengths but you know they all
have weaknesses as well
he has those long strides and the the
court awareness is already there
certainly on the defensive end but even
offensively now I I think in his debut
you saw him put the ball on the floor
maybe a little bit too much a little bit
of a loose dribble on a few possessions
but the Highlight to me in that first
game was him kind of running the the
break and showing some point guard
Vision with the underhanded shovel pass
uh to a teammate for a wide open
um score at the bucket when all the
defensive attention was on him and you
know that is the next level of
dissecting the game um not just going
for the the obvious play there and then
also offensively we saw in the second
game that drop step and when you're
talking about his length uh if he goes
to that drop step and you know kind of
the over the shoulder hook shot you
can't touch it it's unguardable
um he continues to develop that I mean
he's going to be lethal Dave mcmenaman
covering the NBA for ESPN if this Spurs
got scoot Henderson
Greg Popovich's future would be what
a lot of wine then the long Italian
dinners I I don't think you'd be signing
a five-year extension uh to to continue
to coach as he approaches 80 years old
I'll say I'll put it that way
scoot that's no knock on scoot but the
Victor uh you know the entire Victor
story it it feels almost predestined for
him to be in an organization like the
Spurs coached by a guy like Greg
Popovich what leverage do the
Trailblazers have with Dame Lillard in
the Miami Heat
I'm not so sure how much you know other
than the fact that you know there is no
trade clause um that that Dean will have
to be able to block a trade should he
decide he doesn't like that situation
and that would allow the Blazers
obviously to to find any sort of
situation out there that they felt like
they can get the best deal from and
ultimately maybe that does make this a
two or three or four team trade if they
can get the Clippers or the Knicks or
the Sixers involved with some of their
assets but uh you know there's the next
leverage play would be and I covered a
similar situation like this in 2017 when
Kyrie Irving asked for a trade and the
Cavs didn't find a trade partner until
August uh with the Boston Celtics and
you know August that's when the murmurs
started coming out well
you know I I do have this bulky knee
that I I could get that knee cleaned up
and and you know if you if I'm still in
Cleveland when training camp starts so I
may not be ready to be on the court
because I may got to get this this new
fix that would be the play that that
Damian Lillard's Camp could make
it it would be well you know you want to
keep me in Portland you're not going to
see me on the court what about James
Harden
James and I was speaking to a bunch of
folks about this uh Sunday evening uh
the signals right now is that he will be
back with the Philadelphia 76ers
um obviously we opted in to that last
year of his deal that didn't find the
market he was expecting uh with
certainly with the Houston Rockets you
know they were they had their money
elsewhere in Dylan Brooks and Fred Van
Vleet uh but as of right now
um with you know certainly no momentum
appearing on a deal to the Los Angeles
Clippers and Philadelphia obviously
still needing what he does without
finding a replacement for him uh it
looks like there's a pathway for him to
come back to the Sixers next year yeah I
think he ran out of options I think he
played his hand and uh felt like the
Rockets as an organization and their
players didn't want him back because
that would stunt their growth I thought
Fred Van Vleet was a great signing I
don't know who they were bidding against
for Dylan Brooks but uh they got Dylan
Brooks and uh I think he said I'm in
everybody's head every single night or
something like that like uh you might be
in your own head a little too much there
Dylan Brooks
he knows how to play the heel though
I'll give him that well I don't think he
embraced it though Dave when it really
when when when we wanted you to embrace
it like you want to be a tough guy then
all of a sudden he's like I don't want
to be a tough guy anymore I you know I
don't want to be uh you know the villain
Dylan
well LeBron James I guess is not to be
trifled with is one lesson he learned
from that playoff series against the
Lakers but certainly uh you know even
though we all were a little shook in the
industry by seeing the report that the
Grizzlies would welcome him back under
no circumstances whatsoever uh whatever
he did however he played on the court
never he marketed himself outside the
court uh it resulted in an 86 Million
Dollar Payday oh I know I know I know
hey Dave thanks for joining us we
appreciate your time and songs thanks
Steph that's Dave mcmenamin he covers
the NBA for the Mothership